so this is not the type of story I would normally
talk about, but it is kind of a perfect [inaudible]
like
mix of pop culture and current events with
the ongoing V, uh, gun violence issues that
we have in the United States. So I do want
to take a few minutes to talk about it. A,
a group of people showed up at a Popeye's
fast food restaurant and demanded fried chicken
sandwiches at gunpoint. This was in Houston,
Texas. And to understand this, you need to
understand what's been going on with Popeye's
and chicken sandwiches. The whole backstory
is that Popeye's introduced the chicken sandwich
offering and they did it with a very well
calculated viral marketing campaign and it
became a complete social media sensation.
And while I haven't been to a fast food restaurant
in more than 15 years at this point, uh, I
was still following it as something interesting
from a social and business and marketing perspective.
And these sandwiches went crazy. These sandwiches
at Popeye's sold out nationwide and they've
been sold out for some time now.
It was a $3 99 cent chicken sandwich, I believe.
People went crazy for the sandwich and they
ran out of ingredients and now they've said
we don't know when it'll be back and we're
trying to source what we need for it. And
the genius of the campaign in part was that
Popeye's social media campaign sort of went
after Chick-Filet a rivaled chicken chain,
a tongue in cheek, but very, very effective.
Wendy's jumped in on it as well. I don't care
about this food, I never go to these places.
But it was clever and it worked all over the
countries. The sandwiches are just totally
sold out, so when Houston, Texas, not shockingly,
uh, shortly before 9:00 PM three men and two
women show up with at least one firearm. They
had already gone through the drive through.
They had already been told the store was out
of chicken sandwiches and they tried to go
inside with their firearm to demand chicken
sandwiches.
One report says that an employee lock the
door before anybody got in, another report
says the people did get in, so I'm unclear
as to which a a version of that detail is
accurate. The group reportedly had a baby
with them, but the baby was left in the car
when they tried to use a weapon to force the
store to give them chicken sandwiches. Police
as of this morning are looking for the suspects.
Maybe by the time you hear this or watch this,
the suspects will have been caught. Now I
know I say this all the time. We have a problem
in the United States with people who see guns
as a tool to solve problems. I get that. This
is chicken sandwiches, but it's the same damn
pattern I've been pointing out for years in
the United States. Yes, we have too many guns.
Yes, it's too easy to get guns.
We lack basic gun safety regulations. Ammunition
should be more expensive. All of that stuff
is true. It all needs to be dealt with, but
we also have a cultural problem with guns
and one piece of that problem is that people
think of firearms as ways to solve problems
or to get things personal problems in the
United States. Too many people see as possibly
being solved with a gun, political problems
people see as possibly being solved with a
gun cartoonishly here, a popular sold out
chicken sandwich availability problem is seen
as potentially being solvable with a gun.
Now, of course the poor decision making skills
by these individuals are particularly to blame
in this particular case, but there are people
who want to ignore the broader context that
as silly as trying to get sold out chicken
sandwiches with a gun is it's happening in
a country where people try to solve all sorts
of problems with guns.
And to pretend that that is not, the context
is deceptive, it's incomplete and it is not
going to further an understanding of or a
solution to a what it is that we are currently
dealing with here. In any case, I hope that
they find these people as of right now they
are still looking and uh, no, even this is
not going to get me back to fast food. I think,
I'm actually trying to think, I've said 15
years, but I'm really kind of getting up there
now. I think it's been more like 18 years
now. There's one exception when a KFC opened
in a place I was living when I was in my early
twenties I think I did once or twice go over
to KFC as I recently said on the bonus show
and I got one of those crispy strip meals
with the mashed potatoes and that great Cole
slaw that KFC has.
I'm sure it's terrible for you, but it tastes
great. But other than those two ups at KFC,
it's been like 17 or 18 years since I've really
been to a fast food restaurant. Anyway. Uh,
I don't know if you've tried the sandwich.
Let me know if it's actually that good.